[Music]
[Music]
the Massachusetts Bay spank consortium
is a massive funded program where my
words were trying to distribute
government funds and industry funds to
worthy students and faculty members
throughout the Commonwealth in an
attempt to keep the spirit alive of the
importance of space exploration space
technology and make sure that the next
generation is implementing something fun
that those of us who merchants of the
space program has happily members of the
space consortium in this state led by
MIT include Boston University the Draper
laboratory Harvard Tufts University of
Massachusetts Wellesley College and
Westar Polytechnic Institute newly added
this year the Woods Hole Oceanographic
Institute and starting this summer the
thought College was strongly Department
signified
we have programs that involve some
summer internships undergraduate
research opportunities and some
fellowships and those who would like to
find out were caused by this on the web
the speaker this afternoon
Christopher cane follows in a line of
distinguished earlier speakers beginning
with building our 1919 most recently Bob
Siemens last year Christmas subject
prospects in the search for life on Mars
is an exciting one to all of us I was
reminded that our department head in
aeronautics and Astronautics period MIT
had probably said this fall what a
wonderful summer event because now
following the Allan Hills satellite era
the olive oils meteor I find into the
possibility of life on Mars
it says isn't this wonderful man go to
cocktail parties and everybody wants to
talk to you so we're certainly grateful
knowledgeable public awareness that is
associated with the exciting prospect of
life on other planets
Chris McCain is uniquely qualified to
discuss the prospects for exploration of
Mars
PhD recipients in the interest in
geophysics in thanks sorry what I was
Larry so I'm going to talk about today
is is Mars and the prospects for
understanding whether there was life on
Mars
great thanks I mean let me start by
getting the right end of the view graphs
first with just one word choice the only
word shot I use I promise but since I'm
from NASA I'm required to use at least
one word chart I want to sort of
motivate what I do what I'm interested
in this is a goals of planetary sciences
put together by some committee a while
ago and it's the standard stuff
determine the origin evolution the solar
system understand the earth survey the
researchers but the one that I like is
one in the box and in some sense that's
what I I take as my job description to
understand the relationship between the
chemical and physical evolution of the
solar system the appearance of life and
this one got me into planetary science
and this is what I really do and just
yeah just last week when I was doing my
taxes there's a little slot that says
occupation I started writing to
understand the relationship
I've never been audited you know I think
they're afraid of what they'll find when
they come and look well suppose that was
your job to understand the relationship
between the chemical and physical
evolution of the solar system the origin
of life obviously most of your work
would be on earth there's a good sample
this good planet here it's easy to get
to a lot of life-forms but other than
the earth the planet that's the next
best is Mars and so I'm going to talk
about how Mars compares to Earth how it
represents the second example possibly
of life and our understanding of it as a
planet and how we might investigate that
in particular where we would go and I'll
use places on earth as analogs and our
study in places like earth very cold dry
places like Larry said Antarctica
Siberia and now here at the in Boston
all right today's models I'll start with
this image of Mars which is a
ground-based image and if you go out
Mars is in the night sky now you can
look through small telescope and see the
polar caps and watch them grow and
shrink and dark features moving north
and south there it's reasonable to
suspect that this would have been water
in this vegetation and I think that's
what led to the notion that Mars as the
planet most likely to have life maybe
even civilizations because of this
comparison with seasonal change on earth
and partly for that reason and in 76
viking went to mars a little more than
20 years ago and its mission was to
search for life as you may remember it
had a robotic arm to reach out scooped
up some dirt and look to see if there's
any microbial life in the soil we knew
enough by then to know that there was no
widespread biosphere on mars no
civilization no forests anything like
that but there's still a possibility
that there was microbial life what is
Viking fine find I won't go into detail
but basically it found that the soil had
some sort of reactivity some kind of
oxidant bleach or something it found
that there was no organics in the soil
at all so the reactivity is that's why
the activity was thought to be caused by
some kind of chemical reaction so it's
it's not very interesting from a bio
life point of view the results of Viking
really were it's dead Jim there's
there's nothing there why is Mars so
dead I think the the answer is where
the answer let's look at the atmosphere
just remind you what the atmosphere of
Mars is like it's not in the atmosphere
this is the atmosphere would expect
mostly carbon dioxide nitrogen argon
very similar to the atmosphere of Venus
very similar to the atmosphere that
Earth had early in its history in fact
this is the kind of atmosphere you'd
expect the earth to have it's only
recently that it's been polluted by the
presence of oxygen only a billion or two
years life has been producing this
pollutant oxygen replacing the co2 and
of course human beings and their wisdom
are getting rid of this pollutant oxygen
bringing back the co2 restoring the
earth to its environmentally correct
condition which is this kind of
atmosphere which is what earth-like
planet should have so the atmosphere of
Mars is not surprising and you can see
that all the elements needed for life
are here co2 nitrogen water and in fact
as we talk later about humans going to
Mars imagine taking the co2 and taking
the sea off you have oxygen nitrogen
those are the components of breathable
air and here's water basic requirements
needed to sustain humans on Mars are
right there in the atmosphere ready to
get to so it's not the the atmosphere
per se that's surprising on Mars what's
surprising is how thin that atmosphere
is let me just show you the Viking
results for three Mars years six earth
years this is a pressure at the two
Viking sites slightly different
elevation and the pressure is in units
of millibars you know on earth sea level
pressure is a thousand in these units so
the pressure on Mars is a hundred times
thinner than the pressure on earth it's
equivalent to the pressure about 20
miles high on earth this is important in
two respects first for humans the vapor
pressure of water at body temperature 30
centigrade skin temperature is about
sixty millibars which means that fluids
exposed to Mars environment at body
temperature would start boiling it's not
recommended which is why when you go to
Mars we'll need spacesuits from point of
view of humans as might as well be the
vacuum of space also the triple point
pressure of water is here at six
millibars so it says that water is not
going to exist very readily as a liquid
on Mars on Mars water is going to behave
the way carbon dioxide does on earth as
you know dry ice if you take a chunk of
dry ice and warm it up it goes directly
from the solids of the vapor without
forming a liquid phase which is why it's
called dry ice on Mars the pressure is
that water does the same thing and
fundamentally I think that is the answer
to the question or the double question
why is Mars so dead and red I think it's
related to me and the question really is
that at the present epoch there is no
liquid water at any place at any time
this is a profound observation because
if we look at life on Earth life on
Earth is really essentially bags of
liquid water that's what all life-forms
on earth are there's some dormant stages
where they can live without water but
all life and it's growing reproductive
phases as bags of liquid water no liquid
water it's not surprising that it's dead
doesn't mean there's no water on Mars
here's my favorite picture from Viking
showing the surface of the planet see
these white patches this is water Frost
but as I said earlier is that ground
warms up is gonna go directly into
vapour there's no point is there liquid
well that was the the whole story in
terms of biology on Mars would be pretty
dull but one of the things that Viking
did find I'm sure you're all familiar
with these images showing floovio
features on Mars evidence that at one
time Mars had lots of water this is Gale
illness features some 300 kilometers
across
showing floovio features carving through
the ancient cratered terrain you can see
the heavy heavily the evidence of
craters indicating that this terrain
dates back to late bombardment some 3.8
billion years ago this is essentially
the I think these are the most
interesting pictures we have of anything
beyond the earth from the point of view
of life we don't have any evidence
directly of life we have the next best
thing which is liquid water we don't
even have liquid water but we have
pictures of what used to be liquid water
so we're several steps away but still
these are the most exciting pictures
that we have from a biological point of
view once we leave the earth now just as
a word of caution here's another
interesting feature picture that looks
like a floovio feature nice expose and
whatnot but this is Venus and
temperatures were some 600 degrees when
this fluid flowed so we'll have to be
careful how do we really know that these
features are water I won't go into a lot
of detail but the morphology of the
feature this is down flow this way so
it's a tributary system not a
distributary system so it's unlikely
that it's anything but a distributed
fluid candidates co2 water whatever
water is the logical one
the only explanation that really holds
water so speech so we'll take this as
evidence that at one time there was lots
of water on Mars we have other
indications that Mars was more active in
the past for example stars Olympus Mons
volcanoes large volcanoes on Mars
this one's 27 kilometers high five
hundred kilometers across all
indications are that Mars was an active
world at one time we have not seen any
eruptions at the present time we have no
direct evidence of current volcanism on
Mars and there's a lot of evidence of
past volcanism
so it's interesting everything we know
about Mars from the images of Vikings
would tend to indicate that it was at
one time an active planet and has become
inactive what wouldn't what was it like
when it was active well I put up this
picture to bring to mind a notion that
it early in Mars history when it had
water it might have looked like this and
then this picture is actually drawn
based on taking the estimates of the
amount of water required to carve the
channels look at the channels we know
the size of the channels calculate how
much water that is extrapolate to the
planet we deduce a layer of water from
that geomorphological argument of 500
meters thick if you take 500 meters of
water spread over the whole globe sort
of pour it onto the present topography
sort of like that sherwin-williams ad or
they're pouring paint over the globe
just let it relax into the present
topography this is the correct image
that one gets the northern lowlands are
flooded Valles Marineris is flooded and
in the southern highlands of Tarsus is
above ground this is a realistic picture
this is a picture it's an artist
conception of what Mars was like three
and a half billion years ago might have
been like sometimes I say well this
picture is taken by Hubble because it
can look backwards in time and this is a
photograph of Mars so you have what you
guys know better than that so I don't
even try to convince you of that
now when you look at this picture I'm
sure it must remind you of the earth
seen from space the famous what's become
essentially the visual icon for the
Space Age the picture of the Blue Marble
earth seen from space Powell 17 picture
and that's that's really the essential
point in the whole discussion of Mars
and what motivates the interest of Mars
that at one time there might have been
two blue marbles Earth and Mars that's
very interesting it's also interesting
that
we lost one of our marbles and it's
something went wrong with it and so but
to me the most interesting thing is not
that there was another earth per se but
that Earth and Mars were similar at a
time when early Earth and early Mars
were similar at a time when early Earth
had life we look at early Earth we know
that it had water co2 atmosphere
volcanism we know that early Mars had
water co2 atmosphere volcanism but we
know that at the time they were similar
was the time when we first see evidence
for life on Earth and let me go into
this in a little more detail because I
think it's a it's a very fascinating
story the early history of the planets
here is the history of the Earth and
Mars compare let's start with the earth
forming four-and-a-half billion years
ago the moon forming event somewhere out
here four six or something but what's
diverse is really forming the surface of
stabilizing the end of late bombardment
3.8 billion years ago so I take that as
a birthday of the earth April 1st 3.8
billion years ago that's when the earth
yesterday was its birthday 3.8 billion
years ago and what's interesting from
point of view of biology is we have
evidence for life at 3.8 3.9 in the form
of chemical fossils life selectively
takes carbon 12 over carbon 13 by about
a few percent 2% and we see that
isotopic signature in sedimentary record
it's not really hard evidence it it
probably wouldn't stand up in a criminal
trial but you might get by with it in a
civil trial in terms of evidence for
life okay it's but and that's why I call
it possible life here and it's virtually
instantaneous if not before the end of
the late bombardment where 3.5 we have
definite evidence this is beyond a
shadow of a doubt beyond a reasonable
doubt direct evidence for life at 3.5 in
the terms of fossil algae I'll show you
those images from those kind of rocks so
this is amazing in that it shows that
Earth forms and then essentially
possibly instantly geologically speaking
where an instant is ten million years
life appears on the planet
we can't reproduce this in the lab by
the way and we don't have a consensus
theory for how it happened we just have
the evidence that it happened really
quickly on earth and then what happens
just to complete the story is it's
pretty dull for a long time
we have microbial life and then
eventually oxygen builds up multi-cell
your life and then very recently animals
and of course just to perspective here's
the dinosaur extinctions just there I
tried to fit in some more events like
you know election last year and there
but it just doesn't fit in the scale so
it's really this first half billion
years that's the time period that's of
interest in terms of life and planets
and in fact our current understanding of
the biology would suggest that by three
point five for sure all major metabolic
pathways were in place we had DNA life
DNA base life
like we have today with only two major
pathways not yet realized and that is
aerobic respiration which we all depend
on and the ability to metabolize silicon
parts like diatoms do other than that
the story is written by three point five
I call these years first half a billion
years the Wonderbread years these are
the years you remember those old
commercials certainly dates meet in
terms of what I watched on TV but it's
this was the years the formative years
when Earth and life are learning to work
and live together by 3.5 really it's all
it's all details after that well let's
go to Mars this is the same period for
3.5 to 4 when we think there was water
on Mars so why do we think that is
because the floovio channels interlaced
the ancient crater terrain it's very
convenient that the surfaces in the
solar system are time-stamped there was
a big giant time stamping at 3.8 billion
years ago called the ancient cratered
the end of the heavy bombardment we look
at the lunar Highlands we're seeing
material we're seeing that time stamp
we're seeing a surface that dates back
to 3.8 billion years when we look at
mercury we look at the ancient crater on
Mars we see that time stamp on Earth
that time stamps been erased by the very
activity that's kept Earth alive but we
see it on Mars and we see that the wall
floovio features predominantly are
associated in that ancient terrain so
that tells us that water flowed during
this point at some time before and after
and that's the time when life is found
on earth that that is I think a very
compelling argument that if Earth and
Mars were indeed similar and some
clarity really means only liquid water a
biological point of view the only thing
that matters is liquid water and I'll
show you the arguments for that then and
earth life appears quickly on earth then
could it have appeared on Mars that's
the essential scientific question let me
let me answer a related question which
is Earth and Mars started off so similar
why did they take such different
trajectories why is why did Mars go bad
why do planets go bad is it that schools
or bad neighborhoods federal programs
what's the problem we haven't we have
some understanding of that we have some
theories for why Earth stayed good and
why Mars didn't and they have to do with
the carbon cycle imagine the early Mars
early Earth as well with thick co2
atmospheres
these atmospheres are required to keep
the planets warned now interesting we
can't consistently explain Mars early
climate with the co2 atmosphere but
nonetheless let's take is that Mars had
a thick co2 atmosphere that co2 is not
stable in the presence of water
represented here by these clouds the
water will dissolve the co2 to form a
weak acid which will weather silicate
rocks then that result will be the
formation of calcium carbonate now on
earth organisms have made use of this
saturation of calcium carbonate to make
shells and other things but even the
absence of life if left alone the co2
would turn into solid material on ocean
and lake basin floors chalk and
limestone deposits on the bottom of
ocean and Lakes well on earth
fortunately that material is carried by
subduction to depth where temperatures
of around 1,100 degrees centigrade the
carbonate turns back to co2 and comes
bubbling up in art volcanoes this is
exactly what's happening say it Cascade
Range the Juan de Fuca oceanic plate is
subducting under the North American
continental plate those sediments
volatilized and they come bubbling up
and that's the gases that are emanating
from the Cascade Range so the gas is
coming out of Mount st. Helens are
literally the recycling of carbon that
was deposited in the Pacific Ocean so
while those gases and ashes were an
inconvenience to the people living near
Mount st. Helens in terms of the health
of the biosphere it's an important
recycling mechanism
well on Mars there there's no evidence
that this occurs there's no evidence of
plate tectonics we don't see any rifting
so spreading centers I mean we don't see
any subduction areas and we don't have
any anything looks like arc volcanism so
Mars being a one plate planet there's no
way to recycle the carbonate so in some
simple sense we think what happened is
Mars started off with a thick co2
atmosphere at formed carbonate deposits
and there's no way to recycle and that
was all she wrote
100 million years later everything got
cold and everybody died
so in some simple sense we think this
explains the differences between the two
planets that early period of Mars
history this period of half a billion
years between four and three and a half
billion that's the period that were
interested that's when Viking should
have landed on Mars Viking was three and
a half billion years late it wasn't
NASA's fault but we get the blame anyway
three and a half billion years late we
have other evidence that suggests that
Mars was very different early in its
history as well
and this is the meteorite evidence I
want to talk briefly about it
we have meteorites on earth that came
from Mars how do they get here
well it's represented in this picture
what we think happens is stuff slams in
the planets a good example is look in
the night sky and there's comet
hale-bopp racing through the solar
system fortunately it's missing all the
planets it's missing earth in particular
but if it wasn't missing him and there's
always a finite chance it would hit it
could slam with enough force to knock
material in with velocities exceeding
escape velocity the stuff would never
fall back down onto the planet that was
hit and it could go into a solar orbit
and millions of orbits later by some
random chance it could hit another
planet come slamming into the atmosphere
and it would be found in this particular
case we find him in Antarctica well it's
not the meteorites have some sort of
perverse attraction for Antarctica the
way tornadoes do for trailer parks or
anything like that it's just that in
Antarctica it's very easy to recognize a
meteorite because the big white sheet
and the only way a black rock and get on
that sheet is literally falling down
from from the sky well so we have on
earth 12 rocks a dozen rocks that we
think came from Mars this is a very nice
diagram by Jim Gooding that shows how
these rocks form four
our classes of rocks there's the s N and
C rocks eleven of the twelve rocks fall
into these three classes and when I'm
plotting here what Jim plotted here is
the age the crystallization age of the
rock when the rock formed versus a sort
of a estimate of the depth below the
surface at which it formed so you can
see that the SN and C types which is 11
of the 12 are all fairly young 200
million years for the S type and only
about a billion years for the annainsea
type these are young rocks they formed
recently on Mars and we're then kicked
into orbit and came to earth and then
there's one Rock a famous rock now that
was found in Antarctica that formed four
and a half billion years ago on Mars
well these eleven are all consistent
with this planet that's cold with
oxidizing water and no organic stable
these are all consistent with the Mars
we see today and we're telling us that
it looks like Mars has been the way it
is today for at least a billion years a
cold dry desert world probably lifeless
on the surface at least but this one is
not consistent with that kind of
environment and it's consistent with a
warm reducing conditions with organic
compounds stable again indicating that
Mars went through some very deep change
in its environmental conditions from an
environment that was much more conducive
to life than one is it let me just do
sort of a parenthetical discussion here
about how do we know these rocks came
from Mars because it's an often an
interesting point in it I'll just go
over the evidence briefly on that this
is the the logic takes two steps one is
that all these rocks twelve rocks came
from the same place and that's based on
primarily on oxygen isotopes and I just
illustrate that here was a diagram that
shows the oxygen isotopes of different
meteorites and they cluster in certain
classes in the SNC's form a distinct
class right there you can see this is
oxygen 17 to 16 oxygen 18 to 16 and
ocean water would be zero zero on this
plot which would be right around about
there so you can see these farm each
different meteorites tend to form a
distinct class or line on this plot and
there's a distinct cluster there it's
the SMC there tells us that these all
came from the same parent body they all
came from the same place that you told
us that they've come from Mars just
tells us they come from the same place
but what's interesting and the way we
figure out that they came from Mars is
one of these types and particularly this
one the elephant hills 79 double-o one
was analyzed by variety of people
including Pepin and Minnesota and they
found in that meteorite bubbles of air
bubbles of gas and those bubbles of gas
are exactly the same as the gas and Mars
is analyzed by Viking this is the Mars
they are in a log plot and this is the
gas in the s-type meteorite and the
identity function would be this solid
line and here are the points and the
size of the circles of the air bar so
you can see that over a range of nine
orders of magnitude the gas in this
bubble is exactly like the gas in this
meteorite on Mars which form 200 million
years ago and this is not like the gas
anywhere else
it couldn't be this is not earth air
Venus air
Pluto air or anything else this is
definitely a signature that these things
came from Mars and particularly argon 36
to 40 ratio is is different than
anywhere else and it would have been
different
earlier in Mars history so it tells us
these two things one is that Mars
atmosphere hasn't changed much at least
over 200 million years and that this
rock came from Mars and therefore all 12
of them came from Mars so that's the the
basic logic of why we think they came
from Mars now that of course the famous
one is this Allan Hills 84 double-o one
in which interesting features were found
that looked like that little tiny
nondescript ovals and the possibility
was raised that these are direct
evidence of fossils now I want to make a
distinction between the geochemical
evidence we had from the meteorites this
meteorite in particular that Mars was a
warmer wetter place and then this
evidence that there might have been
fossils this evidence is I think weak it
certainly can't be proven wrong readily
but it's not very convincing evidence of
past life but the evidence of the
meteorite that it was warm and wet is
much more robust so there they're not
necessarily the same why is this
evidence weak I think partly because
these fossils are so ambiguous in terms
of evidence for life they're very small
typical scale is about 10 nanometers
across which is very small compared to
microbial life on Earth
and they're just nondescript little oval
shapes let's compare that to the
evidence we have on earth for fossils
the earliest oldest evidence for life on
Earth is this is a picture of that this
is rocks that are three and a half
billion years old this is the oldest
evidence we have for life on this planet
and these are from Australia this is
from work of Bill Schaaf and his
colleague and this is a rock and it's
actually a picture of Iraq this shows a
sort of a lasagna like shape feature
what it is is a microbial mat organisms
living in a mat on a on a shoreline or
an ancient lake and then successive
waves or years mat builds up and it
forms like a layered structure and then
it's solidified and and lithified and it
forms this characteristic shapes
dramatic shape and within these
structures we can find micro fossils
this is a direct picture a in panel a
and this is a line representation of it
and we can see we can lay down a modern
filamentous cyanobacteria blue-green
algae and show that they're very similar
these are this is very good evidence for
biological processes and in fact for
photosynthesis not just for biology but
for photosynthesis for complete
microbial mat communities on earth that
3.5 billion years ago and we can even
make a plausible argument that these are
cyanobacterial mats so it's much better
argument than we have for life on Mars
so the question I want to now turn to is
if we want to go to Mars if we want to
get better evidence how do we do it how
would we do it well I think the answer
is we're gonna have to go to Mars it's
sort of a standard sales pitch the first
rock is free the second one cost five
hundred million dollars so how where are
we gonna go on Mars to buy this 500
million dollar Rock well the lodge the
first thing you might say is we'll go to
the same place where this Allen hills
rock came from and get another one got a
better one well people have identified
Nadine Barlow
Central Florida's identified a place
where this rock could have come from she
thinks it comes from this crater right
here based on the fact that here's a
spot in the ancient cratered terrain the
scale here is about 200 kilometers
across so these are large craters old
craters but there's one here fairly
young crater only about 10
fifteen million years old consistent
with the age of ejection for the Allan
Hills Rock it's slightly oval indicating
a side or a glancing impact which is
consistent with a higher efficiency for
ejecting material so this could be it
may be the thing to do is to direct our
sample return mission the land right in
that crater drill down and pull up and
bring back another rock just like the
one we've got well maybe that's not a
good idea because we might find just
like the one we've got only more we
haven't resolved a question any better
are there better places to search for
life and than this type of material I
think there could be and so I want to
develop the logic for a place where I
think would be the best place to search
for evidence of past life on Mars and
this logic is based on going on places
on earth which are very Mars like so
what is the most mars-like place on
earth it's the Dry Valleys of the
Antarctic let me show you this is a
Landsat photograph looking down in the
Antarctic the scale here is about 300
miles across this is Ross Island this
island here this is Mount Erebus the
active volcano in Antarctica this is the
main United States station McMurdo
Station and you can see this icebreaker
track coming in carrying in Cheerios and
milk and other important supplies for
the base there but the reason we're
region we're interested in is this
region here the Dry Valleys this is the
coldest driest place on earth the mean
annual temperature is minus 20
centigrade and the precipitation here is
tiny compared to the amount of snow we
have outside averages only snow only
snow and it averages about two
centimeters equivalent water a year
which is which is for example 20 times
drier than the Gobi Desert this is an
extremely dry extremely cold environment
needless to say in this environment
there's hardly anything alive in fact
looking down on these valleys it's
lifeless no birds don't insects know
anything it's dead as a doornail I
always take a doornail with me just to
just to be sure dead as a doornail but
on the floor of these valleys there's a
big sheet of ice here's about five
kilometers across a big sheet of ice
that's not surprising this is mean
annual temperature minus 20 ice does not
is not surprising but what's surprising
is that underneath that sheet of ice
there's water so
what we do is we go down there and we
melt a big hole in that wall
ice it turns out it's about it's a
little bit less thick than this room it
varies but we melt a hole through the
ice
about that big hole by heating up some
ethylene glycol and pumping it through
some copper coils it's it melts down
we've got a Sears sump pump that just
sits on it and sprays the water out on
the ice surface we get the hole through
and then we take some non-essential
federal employees which we have a lot of
time to rope and lower them down hey
what are you fine down there
well what are we fine down there in the
water underneath this ice is that
there's algae there there's life there
so the same sort of sign of bacterial
mats that we think populated the early
Earth so here in the most mars-like
environment on earth we find liquid
water that's persisting all year round
some of these lakes can be 30 30 meters
deep or deeper underneath now relatively
thin ice covers persisting all year
round with life in it this is pretty
amazing and the first question that we
try to address was well how can there be
liquid water in an environment where the
mean annual temperature is minus 20 and
how could how can the life survive there
and then what does this tell us about
Mars so we try to develop models of this
and I won't bore you with the details
but I'll just quickly go through is it
sort of a fun sophomore physics exercise
in thermodynamics there's energy sources
there's sunlight coming in there could
be geothermal heat it's not very
important turns out the geothermal heat
in this area is the global average some
70 milliwatts per square meter nothing
to write home about sunlight comes
through enough to photosynthesize about
one percent transmission one ten to the
minus two ten minus three but not enough
to be appreciable heat source it turns
out the heat source is the summer melt
what happens is that indeed the mean
annual temperature is minus twenty let
me show you a plot of the temperature
out throughout the year the site like
this this is a summer winter summer
summer the sun shining January it's
quite warm temperatures can be a few
degrees above freezing which for
Antarctica is very warm and then the
winter comes the Sun goes away it gets
very cold indeed the average is minus 20
but what's important here is that in
summer for a couple days each year the
temperature climbs above freezing
when that happens go back to this
picture you might have noticed it when
that happens the water the ice in these
glaciers surrounding the valleys melts
and the water flows down as liquid water
into underneath the ice cover and what
is it when water is melted it has the
latent heat of fusion a some enormous
for water is enormous 80 calories per
gram and in order for the that water to
freeze it has to release that latent
heat and that latent heat has to be
conducted through the ice cover and it's
that latent heat that forms the energy
source that keeps the lake liquid so
what's essential for understanding this
environment is that the temperature not
that the mean annual is below freezing
but that the temperature gets above
freezing for a little bit each year the
mean annual temperature determines the
thickness of the ice of course because
that determines the barrier what can do
the thermodynamics very simple because
the ice water interface is at zero
degrees by definition the mean annual is
minus 20
heat is being lost by conduction energy
comes in sunlight that's negligible
geothermal heat negligible this is the
latent heat flux and you can very simply
integrate that and solve for the
thickness of the ice and sure enough it
works in Antarctica we can then model it
on Mars and say how long could Lakes
like this persist on Mars and indeed we
could show that long after the rest of
the planet is dead frozen cold like
Antarctica there could be ice-covered
lakes like the Antarctic down to mean
annual temperatures on Mars down to
minus 35 and we've done some simple
climate models that suggest that this
time period could be on the order of
half a billion years so life could have
existed in ice-covered lakes on Mars
like in Antarctica half a billion years
after the rest of the planet would have
been dead
are there lakes on Mars can we find
spots where there would have been lakes
well let me show you my favorite spot on
Mars this is a a Canyon heebies casma
and the Valles Marineris Canyon system
near the equator
[ __ ] was one of the Greek pantheon and
this is her Canyon and in the middle of
the canyon it's a you see the scale bar
here it's several hundred kilometers
long on the order of a hundred
kilometers wide it's got in the middle
of the canyon there's a plateau and if
you look carefully you can see that the
plateau has lamb
nations on the side we think that this
canyon was full of water and that this
plateau is sediments that were deposited
possibly carbonate sediments were
deposited when that Canyon was full of
water there's evidence that suggests
that this whole region experienced
extensive groundwater flow as water
drained from Tharsis through this region
down onto the northern plains so there's
reason to thinking there's extensive
groundwater flow in here would have been
filled with a lake this deep canyon when
filled with a lake with a relatively
thin ice cover even as temperatures on
Mars got down below minus 20 down to
minus 35 there might have been life in
this lake what we'd like to do is land
in the middle of this plateau drill down
to see if there's any fossils and
there's two regions here one is a lake
is a good place to live as I showed you
in the Antarctic long after the rest of
the environment became too dry and cold
for life there might have been life in a
lake a lake an ice-covered lake would
have been a good place to live on a coal
plant but even more important a lake is
a good place to die because if something
dies in the lake it could get buried and
preserved in the sediments those River
features I showed you might have had
water and they might have been great
places to live but it's not clear that
they're great places to find fossils and
I often drive this point home by telling
a story of going to Los Angeles which I
don't recommend but if you do go to Los
Angeles to visit the La Brea Tar Pits
here's this big Tar Pits and there's all
sorts of fossils of saber toothed tigers
and wolves and you think why did they
live in Tar Pits well they didn't live
in Tar Pits it's just a Tar Pits is
where evidence of them are preserved the
same challenge is going to be on Mars
it's not enough to find place where
there is life we have to find place
where the evidence of that life is
preserved and in this case Nature has
been kind to us in that a lake bed I
think provides both examples it provides
an environment which would have
supported life long after the average
and it also provides an excellent
environment for preserving evidence of
that life as fossils unfortunately they
won't let us land anywhere near this
lake you look at for example the air
lips on Pathfinder it's 160 kilometers
it's about like that so you've got a
reasonable chance of getting a 5
kilometer cliff and rolling down and the
project manager doesn't like that so
they they want us to find a lake bed
that's easier to get to one that's near
an airport or something like
so so we've been we've been trying to
find that and we think we've got one and
that's this this one right here this is
our practical site this is a lake chef
crater in the southern ancient cratered
Highlands you can see from the scale bar
it's about 100 kilometers across there's
a river Madame Valles it flowed in and
we think these sediments are off
basically deposited when this Canyon
crater was full of water we think this
was a crater lake with deep sediments
deposited when it was full of water so
and it's much smoother and flatter no
cliffs here easy target land in the
middle of the rover drive around head
down cross the shoreline go up the creek
we could be up the creek on Mars and
find what we're looking for so this is
our current best best example that now I
want to so this would be I want to
emphasize the point that in both cases
what we're searching for is fossils this
is what was in the Allen Hills meteorite
if we believe it this is what we find on
rocks on earth three and a half billion
years ago and this is what we would be
searching for in these ancient lake
that's fossils basically footprints we
don't actually find the organism itself
we find the footprint so I want to make
the case now that that's not enough that
would be interesting and it would make
my day it'd make my decade if we found
really good fossil evidence of life on
Mars but it's not enough and it's not
the end of the story in that we want to
be able to find something that we can
compare to life on Earth and I want to
illustrate this with a very interesting
graphic that was published in the
journal v reproducible results which is
a comparison of apples and oranges
people say you can't compare apples and
oranges but in fact you have to compare
apples and oranges if you want to
understand the broader category of fruit
you have to compare apples and oranges
in fact you'd also want to compare
bananas and even tomatoes which legally
are vegetables but biologically they're
fruits
you want to compare them all and this is
the point on earth we only have apples
in terms of life or oranges well we only
have one if you look at life on Earth
you see that it's all the same stuff
it's all genetically related we have one
example of life on Earth this is the 16s
ribosomal RNA tree of life from Carlos
showing the main families of life these
are the eukaryotes animals
plants mushrooms and all those sorts of
things are up here in the green branch
and then the bacteria form two branches
the you bacteria in the archaea bacteria
all life on Earth is related there's no
reason a priority why this had to be we
could have mapped out the Tree of Life
and found that there are two distinct
trees to separate genesis of life on
earth that have learned to live together
haha right but it's not it's only one if
there was anybody else we ate them
they're gone all that's left is one
example of life and this is a profound
it's a it's what's called the unity of
biochemistry all life on Earth has the
same DNA RNA code the same twenty
left-handed amino acids it's all the
same well this is what I mean by one
data point if we want to understand life
as a general phenomenon we've got to be
able to get life from somewhere else and
sequence its ribosomal RNA if it's even
got it look at its amino acids fossils
are not enough we need actual bodies we
need to be able to something that's
alive or something that's dead but still
preserved organically well there's a
possibility that the life could be
survived still survive on Mars not on
the surface it's way too dry but maybe
under deep under the surface there might
be a magma source associated with ground
ice forming liquid water and providing
an energy source for example hydrogen
and co2 for which methanogens could
could be the basis of an ecosystem and
we're now finding these on earth
interestingly so this this diagram
actually was published about six years
ago and since then people are now
finding these kind of systems completely
isolated from the surface of the earth
subsurface microbial ecosystems many
microbial ecosystems on earth that we
think of as being isolated are not for
example the deep-sea vents because they
rely on oxygen from the upper atmosphere
now finding ones that are truly
anaerobic chemoautotrophs existence in
the subsurface on earth there's been at
least one and so it's possible that deep
underground on Mars life is still there
we can dig it up and drag it here and
analyze it and see if it maps onto our
tree of life why would we care about it
why was it possible that it might just
map onto another diagram here is that as
I was saying
Earth and Mars were habitable early in
their history when there was a lot of
meteorite impact and there could have
been extensive exchange of meteorites
between the two planets at that time
during the late heavy bombardment and we
know or we think that there was life at
earth on earth at that time so the
planets early in their history might
literally been swapping spit and sending
microorganisms back and forth it's we're
learning that maybe the planets are not
biologically isolated the way we thought
they were and so it could be that we go
to Mars and find the organisms maybe
they're still alive and they're just
another branch on the you bacterial or
r:q bacterial tree well I don't think
it's actually likely that we'll find
subsurface life on Mars I think it's
it's highly unlikely but I think there's
another way we might get at this
question by actually finding the remains
of frozen March and organisms and that's
again based on a terrestrial example in
this case it's the Siberian permafrost
here in Siberia is some of the oldest
frozen ground on earth this is the colum
our region there's a river here the
coulomb a river that flows cutting away
that's permafrost and I'm showing it
here this is the active zone the first
metre so which thaws each summer but
below that is the permanently frozen
ground this ground has been frozen for
three-and-a-half million years we know
the age from geomagnetic reversals in
the sediments and we know it's been
permanently frozen from the
geomorphology of these ice wedges these
are solid ice wedges here and what we do
is we get with our Russian colleagues go
back away from that cliff and drill down
into the permafrost and we drill without
drilling fluids which is done because
the drill will get stuck readily if you
do that but it allows us to drill with
sterile technique so that the core we
pull out the inside of that core is
uncontaminated it's still frozen and
clean we break it open look for
organisms we find that there's still
viable bacteria frozen in this ground
for three and a half a million years
three and a half million years frozen
and still there temperatures minus ten
well what does that imply from our as
well Siberia frozen in the ground minus
ten three million years question then is
is there freeze-dried life on Mars well
on Mars we need it to be frozen for
three billion years
well billions and millions
they sound light but there's actually a
big difference between them factor of a
thousand till that's your Congressman
but it's also a lot colder on Mars it's
minus 70 instead of minus 10 that's 6d
degrees colder well you could do sort of
a hand waving argument that says that
the q10 of biological degradation at low
temperatures is about 3 in other words a
change in reactivity rate for every 10
degrees drop in temperature is about 360
degrees in temperature 3 to the 6 very
nifty li turns millions in the billions
and you could argue that if life can
survive being frozen for 3 million at
minus 10 than it could survive being
frozen for 3 billion at minus 70 and
we'll dig up these frozen Mars organisms
from the south polar region and they
will be alive well the answer turns out
to be no not because of this
thermodynamic argument though dynamics
works in their favor but because of
radiation last year we were in Siberia
and I'll never go again because the
Aeroflot airlines are really coming
apart
seriously but and after we drilled the
hole we lowered especially constructed
Geiger counter just to measure the
natural occurring radioactivity and this
is windblown sediment or in origin
there's nothing particularly dangerous
here in terms of concentrations of Rage
nucleotides but just the naturally
occurring uranium thorium and potassium
just crustal average abundances about a
part per million generate radioactivity
here such that a lethal dose of
radiation is accumulated in about 10
million years if you were to lie in this
permafrost sediment for 10 million years
you would be dead for sure
frozen or not and well on earth we're
looking at survival for 3 millions it's
not a big problem we'd expect some radio
selectivity among the my coordinates but
we wouldn't expect it to be sterile but
on Mars where the crustal abundances of
these radio isotopes is going to be
roughly the same organisms preserved for
3 billion will have accumulated hundreds
of lethal doses of radiation they will
be dead as doornails again will have
that same doornail in our pocket and
they'll be dead which actually might be
a good thing we're digging up marsh and
organisms warming them up who knows what
they'd be like we might be glad that
they're dead they'll be dead but they'll
still be there there there are proteins
if they've got proteins will still be
intact we can grind them up and
through a GC and see if they've got the
same 20 amino acids that we have we
could sequence there are tribes onal RNA
if they even got ribosomes they've got
proteins they should have ribosomes we
could compare them biochemically we
could get a lot further in our
understanding of life than we would just
by having a fossil because we actually
have an organism that we can that we
could examine and so I argue that
finding fossil will be exciting but
they'll be exciting things to do after
that as well that will address
fundamental questions let me now turn a
little bit to the missions that are
coming up just to remind you some of the
exciting things that we have in store
right now this is actually a photo of
Mars Observer which didn't make it to
Mars but it's reconstructed copy will be
on reaching Mars later this year on July
4th Pathfinder will and the little rover
that will go out neither of these will
really address the kind of questions
I've been talking about Mars Observer
will indeed give us better imaging of
the planet and so we could do more
refined analyses and and more detailed
speculations about lakes and places that
we might want to go to ultimately we
will want to go to such a place in the
idea now is to construct a rover maybe
something like this Mars akkad maybe a
derivative of the of the Serge owner
Sojourner Rover but this will be the
first time to really direct some of
these questions land on ancient lake bed
with something some kind of arm that can
drill down or some kind of drill that
could go down and pull up a sample and
see if there's carbonates and organic
material and maybe even fossils tied in
but I argue that ultimately they're the
questions here are big enough and the
problem is deep enough that this is
going to be what humans do when they go
and so this this is I've become an
advocate of human exploration because I
think humans bring a unique skill to
this problem and the only way I can
describe it is by analogy and it's an
imperfect analogy I realize but suppose
you find yourself standing in front of a
crowd of a hundred people or so like in
this room and one of them happened to be
say your mother sitting in the middle
you'd be very instantly able to pick
that face out that familiar face out of
this whole sea of unfamiliar faces it's
just something that we're intrinsically
capable of doing recognizing patterns
and biological systems another example
is you have two little black animals one
dog and one's a cat how can you tell the
difference well it's very easy if you're
a human you know right away somebody
once suggested tasks you throw a stick
the one that runs out to the stick as a
die the one that looked at you like
you're crazy is the cat but we as humans
are very very capable of doing that kind
of recognition and yet it be very hard
at least for me to imagine programming a
machine to make that kind of recognition
or to make that kind of differentiation
so I argue and I met without a real hard
justification that humans bring a unique
skill to the recognition of life even on
Mars and that that will be their major
contribution and their major task to the
exploring of Mars and let me take off
from that if humans go to Mars set up
research bases they'll certainly as is
imagined here be rather self-sufficient
their oxygen will come from the co2 in
the atmosphere the nitrogen for buffer
gas for breathable air will come from
the atmosphere water will come from the
atmosphere they'll be fairly
self-sufficient out of necessity from
Earth and that I think leads to the
question of the long term future what is
the long-term future of Mars what does
it hold and it also goes back to water
I've been arguing that Mars as a planet
with a past a steamy wet past we we have
some ideas of how it got to the present
we're interested in who was alive in the
past but does Mars have a future could
we bring it back to life could we do CPR
on this dead planet well what would be
required the first order what you wanted
would have to do is warm up the planet
so we know how to warm up planets we're
doing that on earth and in fact if we
would produce the same sort of gases
methane ammonia nitrous oxide
chlorofluorocarbons put them on Mars at
part per million levels which is a
little bit more than we're doing on
earth but it's in the right direction we
could imagine bringing Mars warming Mars
up bringing it back to the thick co2
life supporting atmosphere once had
introducing life from Earth and going
from there Mars is the only planet that
real this is really feasible on I think
simple back-of-the-envelope calculations
like shown here apply to any of the
other planets like Venus just it's just
ridiculous this is high what you have to
do to spin Venus up if you were so
inclined
and it's just ridiculous Mars for one
reason or another is very close to the
conditions one would like and we have
evidence that it once had water maybe a
biosphere that could be a blueprint for
for a future let me stop there and
they're very speculative n-not that the
rest of the talk wasn't speculative but
by comparison and maybe we have time for
a few questions
[Applause]
perhaps the crawl
push on you personally sending Duggan's
ofcourse around a lot of enthusiasm that
lady can arouse freshman support
sixteen or whatever and asteroids well
let me answer the second question first
especially since I forgotten the first
we can have to remind me which is that
he was only looking for rocks we're
searching for fossils in life and the
task was a little more complex so I'm
not sure it's a fair comparison but the
first question was does it really make
sense to four to involve humans I think
you can answer that in two ways one way
is that humans do bring I think
capabilities that are useful in this
particular task I think the other way to
answer it is that science is not the
only reason we go to Mars and I think
that one we science is one of the things
humans do and it's certainly one of the
things we'll do on Mars
but from my point of view there's
broader reasons for going to Mars and
those reasons all tie to to human
exploration so I think human exploration
is is I wouldn't say is inevitable but I
think its intrinsic its intrinsic it's
it's just part of the way we do things
exploration adventure whatever you want
to want to call it so I I resist the the
calculus that says how much bits per
dollar can you get with robotic mission
versus how many bits per dollar or how
many papers per dollar could you get if
you send humans I think that there's
more to life than just papers in
scientific journey
I don't know what it is yet but I'm sure
it's out there and so I and I think that
that argument is an argument that will
that I think has some merit outside
scientific circles with Congress and
with the with the public that there's
more to the reasons we go to Mars than
just science and I and I to touch on
part of them is in some sense what I was
saying here does Mars have a future I
think one of the key questions about
Mars is is it potentially a site for
human activity is it a potentially a
planet that we could imagine a large
human presence on at some point in the
future that is not just a scientific
question that is a question that deals
with what do we imagine our role as a
civilization or our role as as as beings
and so I realized it's kind of a mushy
answer but that's the best I can do I
can't if one if one were decide that
only science was the criteria and that
was all that we were interested in then
I I would think that certainly we can do
much better much more much faster with
just robotic probes and we could we
could riddle the planet with sample
return holes and bring them back for
analysis on earth for the cost of a
human exploration but that's that's not
to calculate
right and commutated it into dust yeah
yeah that's a good question the limits
are I know the limits on Viking I don't
know what the equivalent concentration
and the meteorites are but it's pretty
low the limits on Viking were parts per
billion in the heavy organics in the
soil material I believe that the
concentration the meteorite is higher
than that but I I'm not I'm not a
hundred percent sure of that I know that
if you just look at the meteorite in
fall on Mars the way to which organics
should be coming down from just stuff
falling onto the surface of Mars then
you would have expected Viking to have
seen something and so there must be some
agent that's actively destroying
organics on the surface of Mars not
based on the island Hills many rights
but based on meteorites falling onto
Mars carbonaceous meteorites or whatever
falling onto Mars it doesn't have to be
a very powerful agent but it has to be
an agent there destroying organics
well that's a good question and I might
be able to find a charge here that that
answers it in that but it's hard to
understand to predict what the timescale
would be but one can do a simple
calculation in which just look at the
initial and final States sort of a delta
H change in enthalpy required to go from
an initial and final state and then
calculate what's the only logical energy
source which is sunlight so I did this
calculation just take an initial state
and a final state sort of cold and dry
warm and wet and calculate the mass
involves and the change in energy to
Delta H and then just divide that by the
solar constant on Mars
because that's the only realistic energy
source that we have available to
harnesses so that number if that number
is 10 to the 8th well go home and think
of something else
but that no those numbers aren't 10 to
the 8th those numbers are 1 of order 1
which means that if with perfect
efficiency you could use every single
photon you can undergo these changes in
a year well obviously you can't a
perfect efficiency but the efficiency
first say greenhouse effects can be
quite high they can be on the order of a
few percent if we were to introduce
parts per million of these gases on Mars
they could the efficiency for traffic
storms you could be on the order of a
few percent which means that on
timescales of 100 years or so
Mars could be warm and and quite
pleasant compared to today wouldn't be
breathable but it would be warm the one
place where this calculation doesn't
order well is down here when you talk
about making oxygen then the timescale
is 17 years but if you look at the only
way we know how to do that on a global
scale it's with self-replicating
machines called plants their efficiency
on earth which presumably is maximized
because they've been working on this for
millions of years is 10 to minus 4 and
then you get a number that's way out
there at time of five years so this is
the only way I can answer that it's not
a prediction it's just a an energy
efficiency calculation
yep
yep we're not gonna start plate
tectonics on Mars yep yeah eventually
it'll go back and our estimate for how
long that took is about ten to eight
years ten to seven 28 years so when I
view it as you're spreading the mortgage
payments out over ten and seven eight
years now that's short compared to the
lifetime of a planet but it's long
compared to congressional funding cycles
or even lifetimes it's even long
compared to a civilization so I I think
that and maybe in ten to the eight years
somebody else will have a good idea for
what to do next so I think it's yeah we
don't solve the problem for all time but
nothing is solved for all time even
earth is not habitable for all time I
mean we're we're a middle-age planet at
best we've got another as long to live
as we've lived maybe even less depending
on your belief in those scenarios for
co2 and solar luminosity so nothing
lasts forever despite what you've heard
on the ratio well I I think it's
unlikely and I based this is a gut
feeling we have no data that argues
against it I base it on two to intuitive
senses one if we look at Mars we don't
see any evidence of recent activity
granted the snc meteorites indicate
volcanism 200 million years ago
that's yesterday geologically speaking
maybe they're subsurface heat but
subsurface heat isn't enough when you
subsurface he's and subsurface
groundwater and we need chemical
production it just looks like there's
too many ifs geologically biologically
it means we have to postulate a biased
view that can sustain itself that can
solve recruitment and dispersal problems
you know one geothermal site goes off
how's it going to get to the other one
that sort of issues over billions of
years it just you know my sense of it is
no now people with all the same data say
that their sense of it is yes it's worth
looking for so that's just the what just
the differences of opinion
well the for contamination problem is is
a big issue because if we go to Mars we
might see a signal that's biological
that's due to something we carried with
us which would cause a big problem in
future missions
so suppose we went to Mars with an oven
to analyze volatiles that took a sample
and heated it up and that sample was
contaminated and we saw a signature of
reduced gases coming out and that would
be a disaster because that would then
NASA's bureaucratic machinery would kick
in and say evidence for life everybody
stop
we got to worry about this when it's
really just contamination from Earth so
I think the for contamination problem is
mostly - it's mostly just doing things
properly and cleanly it's the same thing
in a lab aseptic technique so you don't
culture your yourself or your ecoli in
terms of your experimental results now
I'm advocating for contamination on
purpose later on where you don't
accidentally bring gunk with you you
purposely bring gunk with you so it's a
it's a different point of view
controlling it is much harder on human
exploration but it's not impossible we
do biological collection with aseptic
technique all the time biologists have
been doing it for field biologists been
doing it for centuries it's it's it's a
doesn't take a rocket scientist takes
about one sister
right no that's a good point there's two
points there one is just expenses in
space versus expenses on earth and I
would I would apply that logic to the
whole federal budget not just the space
program which is a trivial fraction of
it there's a lot of things which I think
we shouldn't be buying and should be
building better schools instead that's
that's one issue the other issue is you
know do we really want to go to a planet
and change its its natural course of
affairs and I've only been answering the
question of how I just doing numbers
here now we come to the question of
should should we is this something we'd
really want to do and it really boils
down to what do we think is important in
the environment the environment per se
or the fact that the environment has
life in it on earth there's no
distinction
it's degenerate case because the
environment on earth is biological every
corner of the earth is connected to some
biological component on Mars that
there's a splitting in that degeneracy
and it's not to say there's a distinct
difference between a between a biosphere
and an environment on Mars so now I'm
speaking just my own personal opinion I
vote for life I'm a admitted now life
chauvinist I think life's a great thing
and I think if we could spread life
beyond Earth that would be a good thing
to do just a personal opinion it's not
not official NASA policy I'm working on
it
well I don't think it's a compare I
don't think it's it's either or I think
what we might learn about Mars
information that would be relevant to
maintaining earth I think we we have
assumed there's a species management
responsibilities for Earth whether we
like it or not and so we have to take a
course in planning management and I
think most of that course is going to be
studying earth but occasional field
trips to other planets I think are in
order
and I think Mars would tell us a lot if
we try to build a biosphere on Mars I
think that lesson will be very useful I
remember years ago building a motorcycle
from parts and that was a profound
lesson on how that motorcycle worked it
didn't work when I tried to start it
after I built it by the way which is
another lesson but I think studying Mars
will be part of learning to manage the
earth it's not an alternative I don't
think it's a that they're in that
relationship at all we just don't have
any choice to manage your polar
that's an interesting instrument the
tiga instrument on Mars 98 will land
it's about 70 degrees south on the polar
terrain the polar terrain isn't the best
place to search for evidence of past
life because it's relatively young so it
it's not in the it's not my
understanding of the material they'll
sample is that they're probably seeing
stuff that's on the order of ten to the
six ten to seven years old so it's not
really going back into the ancient stuff
we'd really want to drill down I think
deep enough that were below the annual
wave and probably deep enough that were
below the obliquity wave so changes in
obliquity so two really deep down to get
old stuff that's been frozen for
billions of years
but the Teagan instrument may find
something that's an example where for
contamination matters if if it's if it's
season it's evolved gases methane and
that turns out to be something that they
cooked that they brought with them you
know piece of bill Boynton's pizza or
something you know that's going to be a
big problem
Wow sterilization isn't required I think
it's just clean cleanliness clean room
technique I think that's the protocols
on ninety-eight are adequate for for
contamination
today and a quiz so the rest of I told
you an hour ago you're in for an
exciting time I underestimated even what
what Chris was produced for us mr.
Carrigan
it says certificate of appreciation
that's an understatement
Chris you did a wonderful job where
necessary my party
[Applause]